[Music]
people are returning to vegas once again
to get married the bridal shop business
devastated by the pandemic is now seeing
a steady increase in business
most brides have either you know pushed
back to this year and they're just going
to do it no matter what
i think a lot of brides are just sick of
pushing things back and they're
realizing that they need to get married
eventually
we caught up with taylor kotke marketing
manager of brilliant bridal in las vegas
the company has several other locations
across the southwest u.s but
their vegas location was hit the hardest
during the shutdown and during a time
when brides were canceling weddings
the store's busy season is typically
january through march and they are
finally
seeing business return we have been
seeing the last couple months
more and more brides coming in from out
of town saying that they're getting
married in a few days
we had a bride come in saying that they
were getting married that night and all
of our staff helped her do her makeup
her nails her hair we can do it all not
just a dress
brilliant bridal has dresses ready to go
off the rack they held a mini bridal
show this past weekend letting folks
know they're open for business abiding
by all social distance policies